Lex an den nordstream Pipelines in der
Nacht zum 26 September 2022 hatten
Explosionen die Nord Stream 1 und 2
zerrissen schnell war klar ein
sabotageaktt jetzt ist deutschen
Ermittlungsbehörden offenbar ein
Durchbruch gelungen eine pro-ukrainische
Gruppe soll für die Explosionen
verantwortlich sein wer sie beauftragt
hat noch unklar Recherchen der ARD
zufolge begann der Angriff auf die
Pipelines von Deutschland aus am 6
September 2022 knapp drei Wochen vor den
Explosionen soll sich ein sechsköpfiges
Kommando in Rostock an Bord einer
gemieteten Yacht begeben haben die
Ermittler von zwei Tauchern zwei
Assistenten einem Kapitän und einer
Ärztin aus bislang nicht namentlich
identifiziert professionell gefälschte
Ausweise sollen benutzt worden sein ein
Tag später soll die Gruppe auf dem Darß
am Hafen von wieckstation gemacht haben
die Spur der Yacht verliert sich
zunächst in der Nähe der dänischen Insel
Christian zög bei Bornholm haben sie
dann zurückgegeben worden sein
Kriminaltechniker konnten den Recherchen
zufolge auf einem Tisch in der Kabine
sprengstoffspuren sicherstellen die
Yacht soll von einer Firma in Polen
angemietet worden sein die offenbar zwei
Ukrainern gehört nicht der einzige
Hinweis auf eine mögliche Beteiligung
von Ukrainern bereits kurz nach dem
Anschlag soll ein westlicher
Geheimdienst einen entsprechenden
Hinweis an europäische partnerdienste
übermittelt haben doch auch wenn
spurenrichtungen Ukraine führen heißt
das nicht dass die ukrainische Regierung
hinter dem Anschlag stecken muss möglich
auch das bewusst falsche Spuren gelegt
wurden die auf die Ukraine als
Drahtzieher hindeuten sollen in
Ermittlerkreisen gilt das allerdings
nicht als das wahrscheinlichste Szenario
der Generalbundesanwalt der die
Ermittlung in Deutschland leitet lehnte
bisher eine Stellungnahme zu den
Erkenntnissen ab auf Anfrage des ARD
Recherche Teams erklärte ein Berater des
ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski die
Ukraine habe Zitat natürlich nichts mit
den Anschlägen auf Nord Stream 2 zu tun
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat am Abend bei
einer Bürgersprechstunde in Cottbus kein
Wort zu den neuen Berichten verloren ein
Regierungssprecher verwies lediglich
darauf dass es noch kein Ergebnis gibt
auch eine offizielle Stellungnahme der
US-Regierung zu den Bericht gibt es
nicht nur so viel
einige der europäischen Partner
Deutschland Schweden Dänemark führen
Ermittlungen was passiert ist diese
Ermittlungen laufen noch und ich werde
Ihnen von hier aus nicht vorgreifen
und auch
nato-generalsekretärs doltenberg Rita zu
der Zeit nicht zu spekulieren
und unser USA Korrespondent Elmar tives
und beobachtet die Ermittlungen rund um
das Thema schön guten Morgen oder guten
Abend nach Washington die US-Regierung
die hält sich ja offenbar ziemlich
bedeckt aber welchen Ermittlungsstand
welche Ergebnisse liegen denn jetzt
gesichert vor
Geheimdienstinformationen heraus über
verschiedene amerikanische Medien und
das neueste ist dass die Washington Post
meldet wie das Ganze möglicherweise
zustande gekommen ist dass man Hinweise
hatte auf möglicherweise eine
ukrainische Gruppe und zwar haben die
Geheimdienste nach den Anschlägen also
nach dem 26 September tatsächlich alle
Signale an Kommunikation noch einmal
überprüft also
überwachungs-informationen die sie
gesammelt hatten in Europa und haben
dabei Hinweise gefunden so meldet die
Washington Post das ukrainische Gruppen
oder Einzelpersonen tatsächlich solche
Pläne geschmiedet haben einen Anschlag
auf diese nordsystem Pipeline zu verüben
dazu passt natürlich all das was die
Kollegen von ARD und Zeit jetzt eben
herausbekommen haben was die Ermittler
ganz offenbar eine recherchiert haben in
den letzten Wochen die Informationen auf
dem Land aber natürlich auch auf dem
Wasser
und das würde zusammen plausibel
erscheinen dass es sich um eine
pro-ukrainische Gruppe handelt aber man
schweigt sich öffentlich dazu bisher aus
weil man die Ermittlungsergebnisse
abwarten will um am Ende sagen zu können
wir hinter dem Anschlag steht also wer
die drahtzia hinter dieser dieses hinter
diesem kommando-unternehmen sind ja und
beweise gibt es ja bisher offenbar auch
noch nicht jedenfalls wurden uns noch
keine präsentiert also wie gehen dann
jetzt die Ermittlungen erstmal weiter
ja das eine ist man gleich das ab mit
einem anderen Fall der eine gewisse
Ähnlichkeit hat es gab einen Bomben am
Anschlag im August letzten Jahres auf
die Tochter eines russischen
Nationalisten dugina heißt sie und bei
diesem Anschlag haben die Geheimdienste
zurückverfolgt das ist ganz offenbar
Putin Gegner waren die gemeinsam mit
ukrainischen Staatsbürgern diesen
Anschlag verübt haben könnten die
wiederum auch Kontakte in den
ukrainischen Geheimdienst haben ohne
dass die Regierung in Kiew davon wusste
oder dieses gerade zu den Auftrag
gegeben hat das gleich mal nun
miteinander ab in Deutschland wird am
Freitag das Parlamentarische
Kontrollgremium Tagen das ja zur
Kontrolle der Geheimdienste in
Deutschland da ist und das ist glaube
ich ein ganz wichtiger Punkt weil der
Generalbundesanwalt der ermittelt der
hat eigentlich keinen Zugriff auf
Informationen des
Bundesnachrichtendienstes die aus
anderen Nachrichtendiensten zum Beispiel
der CIA oder der NSA stammen und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass in allen
Bereichen sowohl beim
Generalbundesanwalt als auch eben bei
den Nachrichtendiensten genau überprüft
wird welche Informationen zusammenpassen
und wohin die Spuren führen erste
Einschätzung von MRT Wissen vielen Dank
Natascha schenken